hi i'm very well thank you for taking my
call good pronounce your name for me i
destroyed it
it's arisely arisely okay thank you
it was just the sea it was pretty good i
messed it up okay but it's somebody's
name it's important
no no i've i've gotten aerosol and
that's great well i didn't do that yeah
all right how can we help
i have a predicament i'm in the middle
of a divorce
i get to keep the house my girls are
staying with me
um when's 19 the other one is 17. um
there's no
alimony you try to support anything into
the equation the house is paid in full
and i am going to pay him out
200 200 000 so my question
is whether i take out a loan to pay him
that amount or my attorney indicated i
could take a
penalty free that money from my 401k i
don't know what to do
which option would be better lose the
interest on my
401k by doing that or
have this other language without the
uncertainty of me now being had a
household and
having your income all the bails and
everything
um when how about 120.
okay well i
hate how you got here i hate how you got
here but if you call me up and said i
have a two hundred thousand dollar
mortgage on a 15-year fixed rate and i
make 120 000
a year and i got two teenagers i
wouldn't be panicked hearing that
but i don't i don't like how we got here
obviously you don't either it's been
painful
exactly um i'm just you know i've always
had the cushion of
having him as a backup um but me now
being the soul hit a household
yeah how old are you debt free would
give me 50.
okay so i mean if you take out a 15-year
mortgage of 65 the house is paid for or
sooner if you pay it off early right
yeah and as the kids grow and move out
you know you're going to have more
margin and room in your budget to throw
serious money at this house and get it
paid off early
so yeah i think you take out a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage
okay and don't listen to your attorney
financial advice he's not very smart
no it was just because my i don't you
know coming into having all this
obligation now on me and the
responsibility um i wasn't
if you told me you made 70 000 i'd be
telling you to sell the house you
understand that
okay yeah yeah i definitely couldn't
afford to live there
because of this horrible situation
you've gone through i'm so sorry
so right thank you no fun at all how
long were you married
22 years how you doing
hanging in there sounds like it yeah
here's what we're gonna do i want you to
go through ramsey plus for a year i'm
gonna pay for it
which puts you into financial peace
university and puts you into every
dollar premium
and shows you how to handle money
because somebody needs to give you a hug
right now and that's me and ken okay
thank you so much i appreciate it and i
appreciate this advice i've been
one day debating one option one day
debating the other and i'm just
trying to figure out long term what
would be the best well the problem is
none of these options are
wonderful because of a less than
wonderful situation
yeah and so it's it's not good but
you're going to get through it
and we're going to show you how we'll
walk with you kiddo i'm sorry